(laughing)
- No, you are not serious.
- Hey, what's so funny?
- It's like a whole big
thing, don't worry about it.
- Okay.
(laughing)
- No, that didn't happen,
that's not a true story.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
- How would that even work?
- [Voiceover] No, like,
so you just like...
And then she grabs the silk
scarves, but this time...
And you have to remember,
it's four people at this point, not two.
And you can make anything happen
with enough lube and WD-40.
- Oh my God.
- And like it's kinda like a clown car,
but with a human body.
- Oh my God.
- [Voiceover] This is, what...
- Erin, get back to work!
They're not your real friends, okay?
I pay you all to be here.
- Oh, God.
(laughing)
Yes!
- [Voiceover] I know!
- (laughing) Yes!
Yeah.
- Oh, I don't know if I washed that hand.
Sorry.